Back in the ' 50s, '60s, '7s, ' 80s, the
government of this country had a lot of
wealth. You know, it owned schools, it
owned hospitals and that meant it could
provide public services. That collapsed
during the 90s and 2000s and then during
COVID massively collapsed negative.
Where has that wealth gone now? There's
this there is a phenomenal naivity about
wealth in the economic conversation.
Now, if you do not get that wealth back,
you have no choice but to shut the
welfare state down. Which is why I was
screaming at government before the
election. I was screaming at Labour
Party because we knew they were coming
in. listen, you need to do something
about taxation. You need to do something
about wealth. They were naive to that.
They've walked into the situation.
They've got no wealth. They're bankrupt.
The rich are super rich. They are
unwilling to tax them. And now they're
left with basically no choice but to
shut the welfare state down. Listen,
this is what happens if you are naive
about wealth. Wealth is hemorrhaging
from government, from the middle class
to the rich. If you do not stop that
flow of wealth, you have no no choice
but to shut down the welfare state that
our grandparents and great-grandparents
fought and died